liberals are reeling from a wave of
political calamities that could have
serious legal consequences Republicans
are calling for a second special counsel
to investigate the FBI's handling of the
Clinton email probe congressman Devin
Nunez continues to expose severe FISA
abuses and former Obama officials are
facing new scrutiny but first tonight we
start with a major battle raging between
the Trump administration and the liberal
State of California the Department of
Justice now looking into a possible
obstruction of justice charge against
the mayor of Oakland this comes after
the mayor alerted illegal immigrants in
the California Bay Area the federal
immigration authorities were preparing
to conduct raids the acting ice director
is slamming that mayor of Oakland take a
look what she did is no better than a
you know a gang look out yelling police
when I when a police cruiser comes in
the neighborhood except she did it the
entire community I mean it's beyond the
pale I've been I've been doing this for
34 years and this is a whole new law to
intentionally warn criminals that law
enforcement scumming being a law
enforcement officer is already dangerous
enough but to give the criminals a heads
up that were coming in the next 24 hours
increases that risk puts them you're
talking about these are American heroes
that strap a gun to the hip every day to
defend this nation and to tell their
criminals were coming the next 24 hours
it's just incredible the head of ice is
also saying that because of the mayor's
warning about 800 criminal illegal
immigrants escaped arrest immigration
authorities were however still able to
detain 232 suspected illegal immigrants
in a four day raid now according to ice
115 of the people arrested had quote
prior felony convictions for serious or
violent offenses now despite these facts
the mayor of Oakland is actually
defending her decision to protect and
shield illegal immigrants here's what
the mayor wrote on Twitter I do not
regret sharing this information
is Oakland's legal right to be a
sanctuary citizen city and we have not
broken any laws we believe our community
is safer when families stay together
president Trump also appears to be fed
up with California sanctuary policies he
recently through threatened to pull ice
and Border Patrol agents from the state
because California is refusing to
cooperate with the federal government on
immigration enforcement
take a look we're getting no help from
the state of California I mean frankly
if I wanted to pull our people from
California you would have a crime nest
like you've never seen in California all
I'd have to do is say ice and Border
Patrol let California alone you'd be
inundated you would see crime like
nobody's ever seen crime in this country
and yet we get no help from the state of
California here now with reaction from
the Center for Immigration Studies
Jessica Vaughn immigration attorney
Francisco Hernandez and former deputy
assistant to the President and Fox News
national security strategist Sebastian
Gorka all right good evening all I'm
going to start with you Jessica
is it a protection of citizens to
prevent ice agents from doing their job
for which they have legal authority
well no citizens one our immigration
laws enforced and Isis targets as you
mentioned are felons criminals gang
members people who've been deported
before people who've been immigration
violators multiple times and they were
going after the criminals ice would much
rather arrest them in the jails but
cities like Oakland prevent us from
doing that they tell the law enforcement
agencies they can't cooperate and that's
why these criminals are on the street to
begin with because ice would have
arrested them earlier if they could and
now they've got to go out into the
community to do so and so we didn't
juris so it's for more dangerous for
everyone all right you know Francisco
Hernandez now you're an immigration
attorney when the
the Oakland's mayor says we believe our
community is safer when families stay
together does Kate Steinle and her
ability now that she's six feet under to
stay with her family does that enter
into the mayor's mind at all well it
can't there's no such thing as a
sanctuary cities of political phantom
your honor you know that no state or
county no city state or county can
oppose the federal government now you're
telling me the eyes can catch 800 people
at the same time but there's snitched
out by a mayor I mean what kind of
secret was it and why haven't they
picked him up before they've been
deported before and they were in the
jail why didn't they hold them then guys
this is you know what we were on the
cusp of immigration reform we thought
everybody was on the same page but the
shooting in Florida okay now you got the
president now dr. Gorka let me ask you
this okay now they're saying that
because the mayor said something you
know that that that really doesn't make
a difference what do you think well just
read the mass tweet I hope this woman
didn't have any legal training she said
it's the city's rights cities don't have
rights u.s. citizens have rights that
are protected and the city has
responsibilities to protect them the
mayor of any city has no power when it
comes to immigration that's a usurpation
of federal authority
she said families have to be protected
well guess what Al Capone had a family
so did Pablo Escobar not all families
are good well but here's here's the
problem and Jessica I'm gonna go to you
on this now if law enforcement federal
law enforcement agents are forced to go
into a city without having the
assistance of locals or at least the
identification of where these illegal
felons and remember they're treated
Francisco wait a minute
the truth is if they are being hidden or
not at the addresses and I've done
enough warrants and I've had a whole
team of cops who work for me then what
you're saying is that you know we're
gonna give them a heads up so that they
can never be arrested now the feds have
to come in and get involved in in the
middle of a society where people are
trying to live safely where it could
have been accommodated very easily by
the locals and the feds working together
to arrest a convicted felon Jessica is
there a question that you're writing
yeah and I'm gonna get to you in a
minute so hang on go ahead in 90% of the
country ice does its work of deporting
criminals by arresting them in the jails
but they don't get that kind of
cooperation in California and
particularly in Oakland that's why these
criminal aliens were on the street to
begin with it seriously
ice does depend on cooperation from
state and local law enforcement for an
operation like this a fugitive operation
because they don't want to get shot at
by a police officer that doesn't know
they're in the neighborhood doing this
kind of operation and perhaps that's
where the mayor got tipped off who knows
well but she's also basically telling
people to resist arrest which is absurd
also all right but this has consequences
there people may be harmed because
there's so much chance who took the
mayor's warning went you know disappear
let me go to Francisco Francisco so you
know questions wait a minute Francisco
with the definition of obstruction of
justice I am okay that's an existing
definition okay the definition of
obstruction of justice 18 USC 1505 is
when someone obstructs or impedes the
administration of law under which any
pending proceeding is being had before
any agency of the United States to me
construction of justice is what this
mayor should be charged with if ice
knows that this mayor runs what
supposedly is a sanctuary city and the
secret gets out to her what kind of a
secret do we have it ice and Department
of Homeland Security guys Department of
Homeland Security does not need the
cooperation of a mayor of a county or in
this state yet the information for you
know I don't care if she assists them I
care if she obstructs them go ahead
Sebastian
again your guest isn't answering the
point here the mayor is treating illegal
immigrants as a protected class they are
not a protected class they are illegal
immigrants and more than 150 of them
have committed serious violent offenses
since when does Amer protect people who
have committed serious felonies all
right so they have been convicted of why
haven't they picked them up yet because
like this mayor is hiding them and
alerting them wait wait a minute Jessica
wait a minute Jessica because the locals
are letting them out the side door when
they know ice is coming so the feds
cannot protect American citizens show
and tell me what's true and what isn't
true go ahead Jessica it's not true it's
Oakland Oakland San Francisco and and
the entire state of California does not
cooperate with ice they release criminal
aliens that Isis identified through
biometrics who are deportable from the
country but they refused to allow ice to
come and pick up these individuals
that's why they're on the stand again
goes to get them the my is that a lie it
was can this can disable the federal
government a city jail can disable the
federal government and keep them from
picking somebody up we do it every day
your honor you know that's like a lers
on drug trial the time to make arrests
we break through the doors at 5:00 in
the morning but if they're not there
because they got a tip then I can't
arrest them Sebastian let's go princess
let's go eight years under Obama it was
federal policy from the top down catch
and release
even at the border and then encouraging
the creation of century cities that's
what we've had for eight years it
stopped on Johnny the 20th but these
people are aiding and abetting criminals
all right well let's see if Jesse did
you forget that President Obama at the
port at 2.5
finally happened during the Obama
administration Jessica last question to
you when the when the Governor Jerry
Brown says we protect all of our people
from criminals and we defend everyone
who comes here for a better life
she did say that Jerry Brandt yeah
obviously citizens of California needs
some sanctuary from their legislature
and their governor and from mayor's like
this because they're creating a public
safety hazard by releasing criminal
aliens every single day who go out and
pray again on everyone in the community
really saying it's gotta be something
California has trumped the federal
government yeah that's right
they have and they're gonna be
accountable for it now what do you say
if if the president does what he
threatened to do and that is take all
the ice agents out then you guys can
deal with them until you beg for the ice
agents to come back yeah well that's
genius
that's pure juice but have y'all not
figured out that President Trump is in
New York liberal he's his saint they
from from New York he's never even
living that's why we have an illegal
migration across the southern border
since he was inaugurated right to do
with with you know immigration is an
issue that crosses traditional party
lines this is you know for this is a
matter of California politicians not
being happy with American citizens and
wanting to create a new electorate for
themselves that's what this boils yeah
it's a lot of demographics there's no
question all right
in response California Governor Jerry
Brown told CNBC in California we protect
all our people from criminals and in his
State of the State the Democratic
governor issued a strong rebuke so there
you have it for saying it never said it
now I'm gonna end up give you some
either gay youth to come I'm gonna give
you the opportunity 30 seconds tell me
why what the ice agents are doing should
be blocked by local politicians in
California it
ice ice does not need the assistance of
city states or counties ice in doing
djaro let the troops do what they do the
troops know what they do is the promise
with politics and you got everybody
crawfish and we were on the cusp of
immigration reform ER deciding who gets
to stay and who gets to go but now
nobody wants to touch it because we've
got the gun issue
everybody's crawfishing both sides
democrats sudden the liberals could care
less about the dreamers because they're
more worried about guns
look Oh President Trump said I'll give
1.8 million of them up after citizen
trick of tripled what Obama did now you
want to segment the Trump didn't do his
job you answer I'm in your guest was
absolutely correct why would you do this
as a mayor there's one reason they want
to change the demographics and they want
to have new voters made out of these
illegal aliens that's the end of the
message we want to create a new voting
bloc it's nothing to do with safety its
politics but and it is a shape tomorrow
night and you'll hear how they're all
voting anyway wouldn't thank you